[Music]
okay thanks everyone for for coming I
know it's late in the day after a couple
of very busy sessions if you know I'm if
any of you want to go grab a beer and
come back that's cool too it's a little
it's been going on for a while but
anyways thanks for joining us very much
I'm Carter Paige I'm the lead manager
for BigTable at Google which includes
the cloud BigTable team and we have
George McMullen who's the senior
director of product at a charts hi
everybody and the two of us we're gonna
be presenting about bigquery federated
queries on the cloud big table and how I
charts uses it so cutting straight to
the chase we just announced this morning
that you can now run high-speed sequel
queries on unstructured data in BigTable
so you don't need to hook up your hive
or anything else like that you can just
connect bigquery and now you've got
sequel you can basically turn BigTable
into another virtual table in bigquery
and do everything you can do with
bigquery on top of it so the advantages
of using this approach is you can query
row ranges so the same if you can select
row keys basically start row and row
keys in cloud-like table when you're
doing queries for bigquery and you can
get very fast results as long as you're
kind of ranging that data if you do full
table scans over terabytes it's not
going to be as fast as bigquery is and
it's not exactly what this connector is
optimized for but you can do it in batch
mode I'll talk a little bit more about
the performance trade-offs why this is
etc as we go along the important thing
is to support sequel supports both the
legacy sequel and standard sequel there
is some performance optimizations that
are coming on the standard sequel in the
next couple of weeks and I'll also talk
about that a little bit and all the time
while you're running bigquery against a
live real-time cloud BigTable database
you can still use the cloud BigTable
interface for the low latency reads and
writes that it provides and by
connecting BigTable to bigquery it also
connects BigTable two the bigquery
ecosystem
so anything that can read from a
bigquery table can now read from a big
table table okay so we're gonna run
through here's the agenda basically I'm
gonna run through real quick how
bigquery works and then I'm gonna go
into some detail about how BigTable
works I'm gonna talk then specifically
about the bigquery BigTable connector
and some of the trade-offs like how I
use it wouldn't use it why not when not
to use it then we're gonna get in and do
a demo we're actually going to set up
the connector and run bigquery against a
big table and then I charge is gonna
come in and show how they plug in to
this connector as well so stepping back
a little bit the broader rod roadmap
here Google cloud platform has seven
different storage products ranging from
from a memcache all the way up to a data
warehouse and what we're going to be
focusing on today or these two about
cloud BigTable and bigquery these two
databases are what referred to and as
our analytics databases and they have
different strengths and weaknesses
there's trade-offs for them so what
cloud Makeba was designed for is for
being able to you know scale to
petabytes and Beyond and be able to
provide very fast very fast single value
reads and writes o spot reads and writes
in single-digit milliseconds even out of
the longtail like you know 99% beyond
what bigquery is specialized for is the
ability to take terabytes of data and do
aggregation across it and we do
aggregation analysis and return results
in just a few seconds the converse you
know the inverse of those is not true is
is up is not actually true though
bigquery cannot do very fast individual
spot reads and writes and while you can
do scans over cloud BigTable it's not
optimized for it in the same way that
cloud that sorry that bigquery is and so
large scans will end up taking minutes
and I'll talk again a little bit why
that is but the basic gist of it is that
the architecture of the two systems are
different so cloud make table is row
based all of your data is basically
stored one row at a time and so the
files that underlie big BigTable are
sets of rows one file contains a set of
rows bigquery on the other hand is
actually each file is a column
or you know there's actually a CH column
as a set of files so if you have 20
different columns and bigquery and you
read two different columns from the same
row and bigquery they're reading from
different files and and I'll explain a
little bit more why that affects the
relative performance characteristics of
the two okay so quick dive into how
bigquery works so fully managed no ops
data warehouse me here we have data
warehouse to our schema those sorts of
things that's where your big query comes
in petabyte scale it's super-super
paralyzed for speed you ask a question
of it will spin up you know tons and
tons of workers to analyze your data and
charge you just for the seconds that
it's up you know give you the response
back and spin them down it has the
convenience of sequel so you don't need
software developers to ask simple
questions of your data and it's durable
and highly available like and it's with
similar characteristics to BigTable the
basic terminal architecture for the for
the assets first decade I think this was
published in a paper around in the late
2000s and basically what you have is
it's sort of like a a on the spot Map
Reduce
you essentially have these Leafs that
will each be assigned to a chunk of data
and bigquery and they will go analyze it
they will aggregate the results send it
up to the next layer to the level one up
fixers which in turn will aggregate
again and send it up to the the top
mixer and 2015 we developed a dermalex
architecture which simplified and
actually sped it up where you really
just have one master talking to all the
shards to aggregate things up and
underneath these talk to this columnar
storage which in 2016 we replace the the
previous column i'll storage with
capacitor which is faster especially
when dealing with the with encryption at
rest that we do for everything at at
google and as i mentioned here if you're
you know the important thing of having a
columnar store when you're doing large
aggregate queries is say you have a
table that has a hundred different
columns and you know you want to be able
to read you know aggregate the values
and call them a based on the couch
in column J bigquery will basically you
know rip through those two columns and
you know we'll spread those out and
aggregate them and we were trying the
results back if you did the same thing
on BigTable however BigTable would be
reading every single row as you go along
just because the way it's stored and
that's that's that's by design in terms
of you know what they're intended for
okay so I'll go into how BigTable works
there's some slides that were in some of
the other big table table talks today I
just want to guess it's here like how
much I need to go into deep dive on this
how many people have been to other deep
dive BigTable sessions today okay all
right there's enough people who haven't
let some I'm not going to rush through
this so cloud BigTable it's a fully
managed no sequel database basically
kicked off the no sequel revolution in
mid 2000s led to a bunch of a bunch of
fun open source solutions that imitated
or took direct clones of the
architecture described in the paper or
were heavily influenced Tobias includes
HBase Cassandra hyper table the NSA
built one nothing is called accumulo and
it's basically inspired a whole family
of databases out there the thing that's
the the basic important characteristic
about it is it's incredibly scalable and
so can scale petabytes hundreds of
petabytes whatever and it's very very
low latency so even with large data even
if you're pounding it with a million QPS
you get very tight low latency even at
the tail single-digit milliseconds
typically it supports sequential row
scans so the data is actually you know
the the row keys are stored sequentially
think of it like alphabetical order and
this allows you to do some clever things
in terms of optimization so for example
one of the examples will given the demo
is is the idea of stock ticker data over
time and so if you prefix your Oh key
with a stock ticker you can tell it hey
I want to read the data for the stock
ticker during this window and it will
only read that data there the other
thing that's nice about it is under the
covers because they're stored together
so like we're gonna look at the stock
tip ticker goog
for Google when you start reading the
first entry the first row for that it's
going to go to the file system and
they're stored together in the same
files it's already going to have pulled
that file into memory into the block
cache of the file system and so it's
actually very fast doing scans not quite
as fast as bigquery for the reasons
outlined but but still pretty pretty
good and then the other thing is it
learns and adjusts to access patterns so
as you as you have diurnal patterns
during the day we're going hot or you're
going cold on different areas of the
data a big table will learn about this
and will rebalance and I'll show this
how this works so here's basically what
a big table looks like you know
conceptually you could have millions of
columns so it can be very wide coms you
want to have a single row to have to
have less than 100 Meg's but apart from
that you have kind of no constraint on
the number of columns you throw into a
row each it's a sparse table meaning
that you could have a billion rows and
each of the billion rows could have a
different million columns in each of the
other rows and it doesn't affect the
space you only pay for the row column
intersections that you use you'll notice
that the row keys are sequential
that was the lexicographic or
alphabetical order or ordering of the
row key as I mentioned and then there at
the top there's this notion of column
families in this case it's follows and
Friends and that's the only a schema
definition that happens a big table
you'll define a column family we might
say fan define multiple column families
and then the columns themselves are
actually not defined until insertion
time so when you when you make a
mutation that's when that column first
appears it may only appear in one row or
may appear in many rows that's really up
to use the application developer so
there's a lot of flexibility
particularly if you're ingesting things
with unpredictable schemas this is one
of the reasons that it's it's a great
fit for IOT where you can get some kind
of surprising properties from from
different devices and the last thing
I'll point out in this slide is that the
database is three dimensional so you
have your row you have your column and
then we'll we'll store whatever number
of versions you want you could store you
could store them forever or you could
put a TTL or maximum reversions you know
to kind of manage your data size all
right so this is the BigTable
architecture and that show
the left is kind of a deep dive into
like what what's inside of a tablet
server and I won't go into the details
of that
that'll that would take a while if
you're curious go read the OS di paper
from 2006 a big table that goes into
gory detail in terms of how BigTable
works and how it operates and scales the
way it does the important thing to
notice here is you've got your BigTable
client and it's talking to a pool of
tablet servers and each tablet server
will represent a certain amount of data
that's stored in Colossus which is our
file system and the the important thing
there is the data is not actually stored
in the tablet service so they're
essentially stateless and they represent
and they pin the data from Colossus and
it's our high speed networks that allow
allow this separation to happen without
any performance degradation then we have
a master does coordination and we have
chubbie which is kind of like if you
ever heard of zookeeper it's kind of the
same thing so when you connect to cloud
BigTable from outside you talk to a load
balancer proxy and then it will actually
send you to the - the BigTable knows
we're not gonna talk about the load
balancer proxy right now it's kind of
it's kind of abstracted out as far as
you're concerned and we'll talk about
kind of how how things work inside so we
talked about the nodes being separated
from the storage and this allows you to
do two cool things so one is it you can
you can easily move data around
essentially so imagine you have a
situation where we have this node on the
Left that's getting a lot of access
patterns maybe maybe it's it contains
data for a certain region of the country
that just woke up and what BigTable will
do is it will recognize this in a matter
of seconds and then it will send a
signal to that node to unload the data
and then I'll send a note signal to the
other no to load the data and start
serving this and this happens in you
know a couple of seconds sometimes
hundreds of milliseconds it is it's
practically imperceptible it will who
ever happen to be right at that moment
might get a little bit of latency on the
very long tail like four nines or
something like that but for all intents
and purposes it's transparent and this
is happening all the time it's a very
aggressive it rebalancing to keep things
even the other nice thing is you can
resize to kind of on the fly so you
don't
if you need if you need to throw more
nodes on unlike say Cassandra HBase
you're not also throwing more discs with
the nodes themselves you can spin up and
spin down nodes to increase your
throughput increase your QPS you could
do that for a batch and then after the
batch is done spin it back down again if
you like and because it keeps the the
bouncing nice and even and because the
nodes actually don't talk to each other
you don't get that kind of exponential
price that typically comes from
distributed systems we're often sewer
systems and so it goes in a straight
line from you know if you're three knows
the thirty nodes and the oh by the way
so we kind of give a guidance of 10,000
QPS per node and that's kind of what we
show on the you know on the console and
that's based off of a load test of when
one kilobyte payloads mixed read/write
50/50 if you have very large rows that
are like a hundred Meg's you're gonna
get much lower than this if you have
much smaller rows that are ten bytes
you'll get much much greater than this
so this is just a rule of thumb the most
important thing to do if you're trying
to actually figure out a scale is run
your own load against it the important
point from this is that you can trust
BigTable to scale linearly so as you
keep increasing up you the the number of
nodes will increase your your load grew
proportionally and in fact we had a
customer last year who did a low test
just to kind of prove that they could
and we want to prove we could where he
ran thirty five hundred nodes and got
thirty five million QPS now the thing
that's really cool about 35 million QPS
is they were actually persistent and
durable keep yes these were two discs if
you had chopped if you turn off the
power right in the middle of it you
wouldn't have lost a single byte when it
came back up again so it's performance
is comparable to an end memory database
okay so the connector here so as I
mentioned each database has its own
trade-offs so because Victoria's column
based allows you to query terabytes in
seconds and arrogate that data really
quickly cloud big table being row based
and because of other parts of its
architecture gives you single-digit
millisecond latency so very fast to use
both sometimes people want both aspects
of this and that's why we built this
connect
you previously had to do all ingest in
terms of building a system maybe using a
pub/sub with a dataflow riding it of
both systems hoping they stay kind of in
sync and then you know sending one
program to one or the other depending
what your use case is so the Federation
this federated connector that we're
releasing today basically replaces the
column i/o store that's at the bottom of
the bigquery diagram and just puts a big
big table in there so you can basically
tell a big query like either grow your
Nadeau store or you can point it to the
BigTable api's and it basically treats
BigTable as you know an application
would talking to BigTable the benefits
of this is you get sequel in a copic
table and that's pretty cool because you
have a simple question about your your
data previously you would have to either
go you know instrument something like
hive or you'd have to go have a
developer write a program and run a
MapReduce and hopefully get that answer
to you you know in the next few hours or
something like that now you can do ad
hoc queries you can keep them canned
people who are not developers can
actually you know can can ask questions
about the data that's in there once you
have this connector in place you can use
the same tools that work against
bigquery and you know that that's why we
have a charts up here and they're gonna
show off a little bit about what that
allows you to do no table partitioning
is required so if you're familiar with
bigquery bigquery does big does full
table scans and if you're doing
something like we're housing all your
data over time you'll want to partition
your data like in two days or weeks or
something like that so that you're not
reading you know five years of data when
you're just curious about two days or
something like that
BigTable solves this by providing row
ranges and rather than defining it ahead
of time you define your row ranges at
query time and it will just select the
data that you requested and return that
and so as long as you're keeping the row
range is small the query times will be
will be very fast and you know one or
two seconds and now you only have for
the people who were you know people who
this is a good connector for you only
are storing your data in one place and
that simplifies things a bit to fit
query is seeing the same real time data
that BigTable is the trade off as I
mentioned before as full table scans are
going to be slower if you still want to
do lots of ad hoc full table scans all
day long and
turn in really really quick times you
may still need you to do this dual
ingest if you're doing smaller subsets
of the day you're probably going to be
just fine with a connector on top of
BigTable and the other thing I want to
point out is that BigTable connector is
read-only so unlike bigquery you can
read out of a bigquery get some results
read it into another bigquery table you
can't do that with BigTable however you
can do everything else you can do with a
reading with a read-only connector on
bigquery you can join a big table read
with some with data on a bigquery table
you can even join to big table columns
together or - sorry - big table tables
together
alright so let's let's stop talking and
start typing
let's see can we switch over to the
laptop okay so I have an instance here
it is called GCP demo and I have it
sitting in US central one seat and this
is important because bigquery resides in
two regions it resides in u.s. and
resides in Europe and because the amount
of data that it's reading you need to
co-locate your your BigTable in the same
region so here we have it in the zone US
central NC which is in the same region
as the as the bigquery us region ok so
let's take a look at the data here so
we're gonna use this tool called called
CBT if you use BigTable and you and you
haven't used CBT before then you should
grab it it's a g-cloud component and it
makes it really easy to do simple admin
things for the command-line it's a lot
easier than like using the HBase admin
tools or whatever and so here I just
basically said I read read the first row
of you know the data in this table
ticker and start with the rope the first
row that matches the prefix cooks so we
see actually the opening of the opening
day on the stock market for Google on
August 19th 2004 and it closed at $50
that day we've got a high and a low and
open the volume there is zero some of
the data in here is based on what what
year was or whatever is some for both
the volume and the open
can sometimes be zero so just an
artifact of the data essentially but we
want to do I mean if you wanted to
actually start looking at more this data
using this interface quickly becomes
very clumsy and hard to actually parse
so what we want to do is actually make a
big query table so we can actually do
something do something interesting with
it so let's see okay so we are going to
create a new data set first we're gonna
call it demo and as I mentioned before
we're gonna put it in the u.s. so it's
co-located with the big table that we
have running in US central one seat so
click OK and that's created that's
pretty fast so then what we have to do
is we have to tell bigquery how to talk
to BigTable the trick here is BigTable
has no notion of typing it's all binary
data BigTable doesn't know in an in if
you're storing an integer or a string or
a movie or some ciphertext or whatever
it's just you just store bytes in it so
we need to tell bigquery when it's
reading from certain columns what the
type of that data is and the way we do
that is this is the is the hole there's
the only slightly complicated aspect of
the connector is you just define a JSON
file if you get this everything else is
is brain-dead simple
so this JSON file is starts with a
format and you have a strong you have a
reserved term for the format for
BigTable so you put an all cast BigTable
and they don't be looking for a source
URI to define where that BigTable lives
so we point to the big table API so
Google API use comma slash BigTable we
point to the project name sorry the
project ID I point to the instance ID
and I point to the table ID then we set
up our options so the first option
that's here is is actually pretty
important it's read row key as string so
90% of the time probably more you want
to use row key you want to use strings
as your row keys on BigTable it gives
you the most kind of flexibility
particularly if your concatenated a
bunch of different types of data
together the important thing in this
case is if you if you give bigquery
a string roki and you say hey this you
know my real keys are all strings then
via query we'll know how to be able to
select between individual ranges and
that's the key to actually having a fast
connector so when you're you're
selecting between two you know between
two particular rows and it's you know
you're reading that hundred rows or
thousand rows or ten thousand rows or
whatever not maybe the whole billion
rows that are in that table
the second thing only read latest this
is you usually want this set to true and
if you recall BigTable is a three
dimensional database so each column a
row intersection can have any number of
versions it's interesting for historical
purposes usually you just want the
latest one if you don't you can leave
that you can set this to false but you
typically want this to true and then you
actually define out your column families
and the simple example we were working
with today I have one column family just
simply called tea and so we specify the
column family ID there and then I
specify a type here which in this case
is a string and by especially in this
case I'm I'm saying that every all the
data in this column family happens to be
a string that doesn't have to be the
case you could either set a default and
then override and columns that are
different or you could set each column
to be a different type you could say
this is a string this is an integer and
it's but it's important to set the
correct type so bigquery knows how to
correctly parse your data or how to turn
those bytes into the correct the correct
data you're looking at and then here's
the individual columns and you can see
these match up with with what we saw
before looking at the raw egg table data
symbol close date etc all right so the
way we actually create the create the
new virtual table is fairly simple we
use another command line tool this is
bigquery's g-cloud component called BQ
and again if you use bigquery you should
probably have this tool because makes
your life a lot easier you call the MK
command to make a new table and we
specify the project ID of the bigquery
they're currently the same place but
just pointing out is not the big table
project this is the bigquery project we
specify the external table definition
the JSON file that we just looked at and
then you say the new data set that we
created demo and then
a dot and then the name of the new
bigquery table no that's not the name of
the big table table that's specified
inside the JSON file itself we're
specifying the name of the virtual query
that we want to be have queryable inside
of it query now we do that and after a
long time it's done okay so we go back
to bigquery here and we'll refresh and
takes about five seconds so pretty fast
and now we have the BQ ticker table here
and we can do let's take a look at the
schema here and you can see it's
basically got a schema that you know
it's got a lot more kind of layers that
are in here but the things you generally
care about are kind of like you have
your your T dot symbol T dot clothes in
fact what we'll do here is we'll grab
the close date with the close price on
on Halloween let's say so T dot closed
cell value from what's this thing called
demo dot B Q underscore ticker where
Roky equals I'll say good and it'll say
underscore 2016 10 31 okay I'll run this
and we get a closing price of seven
seven hundred eighty-five dollars
basically on that day but you know this
is bigquery so you so you can already do
spot lookups inside a big table that's
not very interesting so you can do some
more interested interesting sorts of
things so let's look at say all of the
let's drink a theme men and Macs for the
entire month of last October so because
the values are strings you want to cast
them to floats we're gonna indicate that
the men here is the men of the low for
the month is a is gonna call it be
called low the max of the high is called
high and we're gonna give it a row key
range we're going to say it's going to
be between this and this so we could
even do a prefix because there you know
you could have a basically a trochee
prefix and just say it goes up to 2016
10 it'll basically do the same thing so
we do that we find out that the low for
the whole month was 17 $70 the high was
816 all right but usually like you when
you're plugging this into report
engines you want to be able to do more
interesting things like build histograms
of data so if you can do something more
here yeah so let's look at a histogram
of the highest high and the lowest low
of each month
ever since Google went public so you run
that and after 1.3 seconds we've got our
hands here back we've got basically the
the range for each month for all 151
months at the stock has been trading so
so that's just showing the raw
functionality but I think you know what
gets interesting is when we can actually
when I can actually turn this in to turn
this into some kind of visualization and
for that George is gonna come up and
show us eye charts so can we switch back
to the slides please all right awesome
thanks thanks rich that's pretty
incredible stuff hey everybody I'm not
gonna do a demo yet another demo alright
so just for anybody who doesn't already
understand or know what I charts does we
help our folks like yourselves
understand the trends that are in
massive massive amounts of data so that
it can help you answer questions and
make decisions and drive actions that
can drive your business and and so some
of the things that our customers really
like about us is the simplicity easy to
use it's a drag-and-drop type of
interface and it's not to say that we
are trying to hide any of the power we
actually do give you some of the power
as well to do some really native stuff
within our interface and I'm going to
show you some of that also you know
multiple levels of aggregation so you
can drill down into the details of the
data while still seeing those higher
levels of aggregation in a DNA hierarchy
that you define on the fly within the
interface and something else that's
really important is single sign-on being
able to use Google auth to get into our
plow
form and that's really important for
folks who don't want to have another
username or password it simplifies the
whole data management and it also
enables embed ability whereby you know
you can use our visualizations or the
entire reporting system within the
products that you're already using just
simple example is if you have a
dashboard you can put that into Google
Sites or you know you can put a chart in
Google slides so how do we work you know
we start at the visualization layer to
us everything needs to be a
visualization because that's that's the
goal that's those are the questions that
you're trying to answer so the decisions
that you're trying to make and so that's
where we start you know except for the
you know this demo I'll be going into
little bit more of the the mean the
details and feeling bath cover to show
you how it's all working and then what
our system basically does is it takes
that visualization configuration and
creates a dynamic query that includes
all the calculations and aggregations
segmentation filtering windowing all
that wonderful stuff and parses it out
into the api's like Google bigquery x'
api gets all the data back pushes it
back to the user where they can then
interact with it so before I get into
the demo I've got a bit of a confession
to make
we've we've never worked with BigTable
at all before we've never done any kind
of integration or anything yeah I know
right so but that's one of the reasons
why we're so excited about this because
now we can offer this to the customers
that we have that have BigTable data and
then they can access all that
information alongside their big query
information in one single place and that
also helps with the the simplification
of data management and they can also
query on it using SQL using the
languages they already kind of know this
analysts already know SQL and most
importantly I think really is is the
fact that they can take this
unstructured data that they have in one
system
and combine it with structured data that
they have in another system and see it
all cohesively in a single visualization
and report but I think the most
important thing for us as a company is
that we didn't have to do any work so
how do I really like that so yeah on
with our demo if you could switch back
over here and a little bit also about
eye charts we run on standard SQL as
Carter mentioned they're still doing
some query optimization so things might
run a few seconds slower oh my god
I might have to wait a couple seconds
for things to load up but one of the
things that Carter just showed and I'm
going to pick it up where he left off is
that query that was showing a histogram
of the Google stock ticker over months
right so I did a little conversion over
to standard SQL is really simple to do
just few a few lines need to be changed
plenty of documentation on that and I'm
already logged into hi charts through
Google OAuth just refresh the screen
make sure that I'm still here and I have
access to all the datasets and all the
projects that I already had access to so
like bigquery there's that demo data set
that he created here's the stock ticker
data set and I can actually use that
query as a data set I could drive
directly by the the tables themselves
but I wanted to use this particular use
case as an example so I'm just going to
paste the query in there I've already
done this a few times practice makes
perfect
once and I'm gonna go create this data
set actually you know what I'll also do
is I'll take this query and run it in
the bigquery console as well so you
could kind of see that Oh show options
disable legacy SQL get rid of cache
results also so right now it's basically
running the same query on actually have
to get returned already I'll hide
options and that didn't take that long
on all this view so we see the same
exact data that we saw in Carter's
original demo it's there okay so now I'm
in our editor and we have the fields
that have defined in that query so we
have the month to low and the high and I
could basically take this and replicate
the same exact output that Carter showed
us in that it just showed you in the
bigquery console it's going in it's
basically getting every single month out
of that data set piping it through big
queries API and then going down into the
BigTable through the federated query
system and now it's going to basically
do the same thing and get the highs and
it's also aggregating it at the same
time so if it were kind of row level
information not pre aggregated through a
query then you'd basically be able to
see a sum where you can also choose
things like account average min max
distinct or you could do other things
which I'll show in a moment so you know
this is great you know it's pretty much
the same thing but I promise the
visualization so I'm gonna show a
visualization instead and we'll see how
basically all of this which is kind of
difficult to interpret just by reading
it you know a few a few hundred rows but
this is much easier right
you can obviously see hey if I invested
in Google in the beginning of time I'd
be doing pretty well right now and and
yeah you know if you had done that you
had you'd be 10x your original
investment maybe even more but most
people they don't have just one stock
symbol in their portfolio they didn't
just put all their eggs in one basket
they have their their diversifying their
putting they may have multiple
portfolios and if you're building an
application that is for portfolio
trading or some kind of trading
application or brokerage application
you're dealing with thousands or even
more portfolios that
contain hundreds of thousands of ticker
symbols in them with you know billions
and billions of trades not just the
purchase but every single time you've
made a trade that's being recorded and
so that's kind of the next use case that
I wanted to show you really about how it
can we combine this information here
that's coming from a big big table with
some other data which would represent my
portfolio within bigquery and I'll just
take a look at bigquery here
show you what my portfolio looks like
and hide this it's it's basic table you
know portfolio name ticker purchase date
when I purchased that the sock how many
shares I purchased what was the price
that I purchased it right so I've got
another query below and you could do
this all within our interface but I
think it's important here to kind of
show the the core SQL this a little bit
more of a technical audience and so what
what this query actually does is you
know it's basically basic select command
taking the information from my portfolio
taking some of the information from the
the ticker table that's and Riven from
BigTable doing the from from the
portfolio joining it just like you would
join any two tables together but it's
great because these two tables are in
different systems so and just joining it
on the cell and we basically have a a
little bit of optimization here where
you're saying okay the row key is from
between the time that I purchased the
stock until the present time and it's
doing some pre aggregation for us as
well just to make things fun if I could
copy and paste this
I can even use this as a data set just
basically create a user entered query
here give it a name portfolio by month
create a data set and I'll also show you
what it looks like on bigquery itself
give you an example of what happens on
query hide options right wow that was
fast too so here now I have every single
portfolio all the tickers when it
purchased the shares how many shares I
purchased the purchase price the price
and the month together so price is
actually the price during that month and
you know what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually going to do a little something
extra here because yeah the price of the
shares currently vs. the number of
shares that I have is great but I
actually want to see what the value is
that that is currently existing in my
portfolio or how it's changed over time
and that's really straightforward simple
calculation I'm just going to multiply
purchase British shares to price and you
know certainly you could have created a
view to do this but it's I think it's
more important to actually do it with
directly within the dataset layer within
our semantic layer because if this were
more complex query that was put onto a
pre aggregated data set then you know
you lose the capabilities of filtering
and drilling down into the data so it's
more important to have that directly
within our layer then trying to do it on
on the directly within the data
so I'm just gonna copy that and edit our
data set and I just couldn't call it
value so you give it a float paste in my
thing and you know what I'm actually
also going to do a little extra
formatting just so it looks good okay so
now I can create a pivot table directly
on this data so what I'll do is I'll
take the portfolio name that I have and
what it does is goes directly into
bigquery automatically gets all the
portfolio information out and then maybe
I want to see the how each portfolio has
evolved over time take that put that
into the columns and you know what I'll
also add it to the filter as my trading
started in 2014 but maybe I'm only
interested in maybe the past six months
so I'll just pick a date range from in
to February to October sounds nice and
then I'll take the value which is the
calculation that I entered in to our
semantic layer and I'll add it right
within there so now it's actually going
in creating that query that breaks it
down by portfolio name over the trading
months and multiplying the purchase
price or the current price for each
individual month by the number of shares
so I could see each individual stock
each individual portfolio and how
they've evolved over time but this is
great but maybe I want to get in a
little bit more detail what about each
individual stock ticker so I'll just
drag this into into our rows and it'll
perform the same kind of query over
again but drilling into each in
vidual stockticker and now we see energy
every two stockticker all the individual
amounts financial and what it's doing
here is we have great we have the
individual amounts but we also have the
higher level aggregation based off of
that hierarchy that I defined I could I
could make it if if there were some
other data here I could switch these
things around or what I can also do is I
could take the trading month and maybe I
don't want to see it on the column in
our level I want to basically put that
up into the rows and show it in kind of
a really more hierarchical level so I
could see now for the month of October
2016 which is the first month that I
filtered by I'm seeing that the total
value is thirty thousand I'm not doing
too bad I can also I don't know how to
double click on your on your laptop and
I could see every single month overtime
cool but again what does this look like
well I just switch this over to a line
short or maybe even an area chart and so
we could actually see how this has come
over time so this is past six months
maybe I just want to see it from from
the beginning
all the way back into 2014 back in the
day this might be a little bit easier to
read so yeah I'm looking at my portfolio
and I'm doing pretty well you know maybe
only 6x not as good as if I just
involved in in invested in Google from
the beginning but I'm seeing also
there's there's a little dip and I'm
wondering where that excess coming from
you know I could tell that somewhere in
in February or April February that that
this dip has and like where's like
where's that coming from because it
looks pretty drastic here but if you if
you
you know if you get into the details I
might see is a little bit of a different
story more detail story so I'm actually
going to take the portfolio and take the
same exact chart and segmented by the
portfolio of every single trade goes in
creates the query that says give me the
part give me the current value of every
one of my stocks in every single one of
my portfolios for all the months that I
want to display and so what I'm actually
seeing here is that my it's not such a
massive drastic drop when I'm actually
seeing is that my health port might the
stocks in my health portfolio and even a
little bit of my stocks in my financial
portfolio has experienced a bit of a
downtrend for over over the course of a
year and and at the same time I've got a
nice big increase in my tech stocks
portfolio so there was just kind of a
slow moving downward trend and a nice
sharp upward trend for a couple of
things and this is the exact type of
questions that people have that until
now they weren't be able to dynamically
answer and especially with data that
comes from multiple sources that they
want to combine into one this is this is
pretty groundbreaking stuff so can we
switch over back to the presentation
mode so you could try it out
if you want go for it I starts net a
slash Google pivot it's available now
again we use standard SQL all that good
optimization is coming real soon
you could ask Carter about it and but
real I want to thank Carter and the team
for creating this it's a it's incredible
I appreciate it Thanks
now thanks George it's a really cool
tool
I mean what's really neat is he didn't
do anything he just pointed at bigquery
and can drag and drop and get a lot of a
lot of information on the data that's
already there where if I wanted to do
that with a with a MapReduce you know
how beat I'll be programming for about
two hours to try and get that I could
get the same results so quick recap so
as of today you can analyze big table
data using bigquery
it is row range optimized for the legacy
sequel the the row range optimization
for standard sequel is coming soon
that's why his queries were taking eight
seconds and not two seconds that was our
fault not his and a couple of weeks the
standard sequel also be as lightning
fast as the legacy sequel and in short
you get the best of both analytical data
stores by using this connector so thank
you there is a URL here that you're
welcome to go take a look at the
documentation to show you how to set up
a connector and play around with it and
you know be be interesting to see what
you what you find it's in beta right now
so you know we're always eager to hear
your feedback that is the end of our
presentation but we have some time for
questions for anyone who's not running
off for beer right now but if you are
running out for a beer I do not I do not
begrudge you because I would
[Music]
you